thanks Claire cotton plantations don't let
the scenery fool your folks life on the cotton
field was not as bad as this was painted
the overseer is keeping the slaves under
a strict watch but in the end they'll give
him the works hello boy quick no in the rope
why it's uncle town in appreciation
st. Claire buys the old slave thanks
Tom you've saved my daughter from a terrible dive
and now we present that famous and
heart-rending scene the death of evil
heaven help little Yvonne a night light
get out your hankies folks cause little
divas going to kick the old oaken bucket
goodbye top Singh goodbye pepper farewell many you
forgot Tom so long tom oh boy
oh boy all it happy landing Eva
Simon Legree's buying drinks for the house
he throws a drink in Tom's face st. Claire
is innocent so he gets stuck for Toms
drink st. Claire thinks he's shot but
he's only half shot this is the first
time he ever passed out in the saloon
come in ah the bidding was heavy for Tom but Simon
Legree gets all the Spade and
now he's ready for a Grand Slam
Simon is a little horse so he orders a snort
little fool of a little simon is now
fried southern style and now for the
famous old time battle Simon Legree
versus Uncle Tom mom town he's up down
he's up he's down boy can Uncle Tom taken
the show there's no hard feelings Legree
will now Nick Uncle Tom now giving
the third Legree Saved by the Bell
pay attention you ball-headed customers you're
going to witness a theme which is absolutely
hair-raising the lies are crossing the ice
the old Kentucky baby is on Eliza's face
to pose with Sonny Boy up Legree's dogs are
next on the track ruler Prince Cynthia I'm
chapter marks and the dirtiest dog of all
Simon Legree the grease smells at our cost
come on boys Eliza's up the river and it looks
like Simon's up the well-known street it's the
finish Liza gets away and leave Simon Legree's
flat on his old plantation water screen souvenir